[Musique]
l'armée française
les forces françaises de l'antre
devaient et doivent
s'assurer de la maîtrise du terrain cela
a été fait
et enfin à moins d'un effondrement
il fallait il faut
en dépit des explications à la
désobéissance et à la diversion
prodigués par 10 des voiliers
notre armée doit rester y reste
maintenue dans le devoir elle a été elle
l'est honoraires
maintenant on peut construire
nous sommes prêts
a
établi un accord
avec les dirigeants de la rébellion
pour ramener décidément la paix en
algérie pour régler les conditions de
l'autodétermination pour définir les
éléments d'une coopération franco
algérienne le général a exprimé son
désir de voir les éléments
représentatifs en algérie entreprendre
eux mêmes la préparation du référendum
nous sommes décidés à
organiser dès à présent
une force publique algérienne dont
disposera le pouvoir provisoire quand il
assumera la responsabilité
de conduire le pays à la décision
enfin le président de la république
après avoir condamné les anciens jeux
des partis politiques a conclu
pour la france
qui traverse
un passage
dure et dangereuse
le salut est le succès exige la cohésion
nationale
avec beaucoup de solennité la suède a
rendu un dernier hommage à celui qu'elle
considère comme l'un de ces grands
hommes monsieur d'agde à marchal dans
la cathédrale d'uppsala le service
funèbre avait réuni la famille royale et
le gouvernement au grand complet la
suède avait tenu à faire des funérailles
nationales au second secrétaire général
de l'onu
[Musique]
paris a pavoisé aux couleurs nigérienne
en l'honneur de monsieur diori hamani
président de la république du niger que
le général de gaulle à cayenne à
l'elysée aux premières heures d'une
visite de trois jours
[Musique]
pour en même temps que l'un des leaders
du monde africains d'expression
française c'est aussi un ami que la
france a reçus et c'est d'abord cette
amitié que monsieur diori hamani a voulu
célébrer en allant se recueillir sur la
tombe du soldat inconnu
n'avait-il pas déclaré dès son arrivée
en france nos pays tout entier participe
à la cordialité et à la chaleur de votre
accueil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après la journée des casseroles et celle
des oriflammes alger devait connaître la
journée des embouteillages l'opération
proprement dite à part quelques points
centraux s'est révélé être un demi échec
aux consignes de l'oas
la journée ne s'est pourtant pas achevé
sans incident les pierres et des
bouteilles ont volé
les auto pompes sont entrés en action
et
ainsi que les grenades lacrymogènes
pendant plusieurs heures un groupe de
jeunes européens et les gendarmes
mobiles se sont ainsi opposés sans
aménité images dans alger fiévreux
images d'un alger où il faut peu de
choses pour déclencher la violence
a bizerte c'est la détente une détente
active pourrait-on dire puisqu'elle
s'est traduite par l'enlèvement des
barbelés qui marquait les positions
avancées dans la ville moderne l'humour
même n'a pas manqué
quand je suis triste français d'un côté
soldats tunisiens de l'autre ont fait
place mettre des barrières qui les
séparaient
ainsi s'est matérialisé le geste de
bonne volonté de la france dont les
troupes vont regagner les positions qui
étaient les leurs avant la grave crise
du mois de juillet première étape d'un
règlement d'ensemble
après ce monsieur messmer ministre des
armées a présidé à la mise à l'eau d'un
navire inédit en france la résolue et le
premier porte hélicoptère de la marine
nationale dans trois ans le bâtiment qui
jauge ans milton prendra la relève du
croiseur école jeanne d'arc qui après
vingt-trois croisière et 30 ans de bons
et loyaux services a sans doute bien
mérité sa retraite
[Musique]
hollande un nouveau bateau de sauvetage
a vu le jour regard tranquille mine
assurée son inventeur a tenu à en faire
lui même la démonstration faisant preuve
d'une confiance parfaite dans son oeuvre
il s'agissait tout de même de se faire
précipiter à l'eau de 9 m enfermer dans
le bateau
au demeurant le résultat fut des plus
concluants résistants insubmersible
l'engin quoi qu'on fasse retombe
toujours sur ses acquis
voilà un inventeur qui peut regarder le
monde en face
avant de s'ouvrir le salon de l'auto
n'avait déjà plus de secret salle danton
dit qu'elle n'est grande qu'à
l'intérieur la simca 1000 avait déjà
livré les siens son habitabilité son
coffre à l'avant et son auteur de cinq
chevaux à l'arrière
bien suspendu stable la simca 1000 et
une arme efficace que la firme de voix
silence dans la grande bataille des
petites cylindrées engagé cette année
[Musique]
larmes de renault c'est la r4 qui
succède à la 4 chevaux et qui a elle
aussi déjà livré ses secrets
on ne s'étonnera pas de rencontrer la r4
dans les chemins de terre voire en plein
champ rustique cette voiture qui adopte
délibérément la formule du moteur à
l'avant possède une soute à bagages
spacieuse mais aussi une suspension qui
permet une utilisation tout terrain
[Musique]
badou pas d'antigènes pas de graissage
il lui suffit d'un peu d'essence quand
même
avec cela un rayon de braquage qui
autorise les manoeuvres les plus
audacieuses
mais les performances des voitures
modernes exige des industries
d'équipements de plus en plus
perfectionnés ainsi est né le complexe
industriel damien dunlop a édifié ici la
première usine d'europe et l'une des
plus modernes du monde
[Musique]
c'est l'univers du robot l'automation
poussé à un niveau très élevé se traduit
par une production de 8000 points par
jour l'équipement de 16 cents voitures
une réalisation qui se veut à la mesure
du marché commun un autre effet de ce
marché commun et de l'abaissement des
barrières douanières aura été de faire
passer la frontière à la production
française de poids lourds c'est ainsi
que les camion berliet ont pris une
place significative sur un marché qui
connaît bien le problème du matériel
lourd l'allemagne
la naturalisation et maintenant tu
automatique et l'habillage définitif des
châssis s'effectue sur place selon les
besoins des acheteurs
[Musique]
paris ne verra pas cette année s'ouvrir
de salon du poids lourd mais on peut
dire que ce salon se tient sur toutes
les routes du marché commun
l'automne il fallait s'y attendre a
soufflé sur les coiffures pour les
matinées déjà fraîche elles ont pris
sept lignes asymétriques que jacques du
tour a créé avec sciences po ils nous
proposent une coiffure gonflée orné
d'une légère frange est prise dans un
bandeau
[Musique]
pour l'après midi voici ninou d'antoine
salvador envolée sur le front léger
mouvement tombant sur les yeux
[Musique]
pour le cocktail il a imaginé une
coiffure plus osés déportés de gauche à
droite très travaillé sur la nuque
[Musique]
pour le soir bien sûr toutes les audaces
sont permises et les ornements briegel
jean clément a choisi tante olga même et
en os le vison blanc qui sied aux
cheveux blonds de nuit moscovite pour
les grands soirs enfin rien n'empêche de
rêver d'une coiffure vraiment éclatant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]